hey leute und herzlich willkommen zu
einer neuen zieht vorstellung und zwar
wurde mir das sieht von n solo kraft
untermain fifa video gesendet ich habe
keine ahnung warum den unterkiefer video
schreibt aber na ja mittlerweile nämlich
eigentlich immer mehr sitz
beziehungsweise fast ausschließlich nur
noch siezen meine facebook-seite
gepostet werden weil ich mir die da auch
alle wirklich durchlesen alle probieren
allerdings habe ich daher den kommenden
zufälligerweise gelesen ich nenne die
welt einfach mal und zwar ist der name
dossier also dr
wie treten und sie neue welt das wird
wieder ein relativ ich sag mal komisch
aussieht bzw 1 zieht der euch gefallen
wird also das definitiv dass es bei mir
am anfang in die immer so dass sich aus
der welt falle jetzt 8 mm auf die höhe
das ist ziemlich geil ich bin dabei -
200 das ganz witzig aber wir sind gleich
schon wieder oben genau jetzt so und
hier sind wir in der welt die sich
gerade aufbaut also wir sind jetzt hier
in so einer komischen wüste blasi dass
ich mit diesem text effektiver kann ich
das immer so ein bisschen so als ich
wahrscheinlich schön aus ich habe es
natürlich dass die vortex pack für die
vorstellung natürlich immer am start das
ding so ich würde sagen also dass der
spawn gewesen ihr fliegt ihr dreht euch
180 grad fliegt hier in die richtung
hier ist erstmal also diese ganzen
blumen kommen von trappe kräfte hier ist
erstmal ein dorf ein relativ großes dorf
dort wird da nichts drin sein weil hier
ist keine schmiede ist glaube ich das
nicht also jetzt auf jeden fall keine
schmiede jedenfalls könnte mit den
virgin handeln usw also seht ihr die
preise von den 111 fall des oberst was
hast du denn hierfür preise für meine
geben als wütend neigert hören doch in
ruhe zurück von mir
magath jedenfalls wenn er hier durch
dieses dings weiter geht seht ihr was
ist denn da hinten war der spanier
könnte noch erinnern genau da hier ist
ein dorf das ist ein komischer boden
und was sind es vier runden hat easyjet
oder geht ihr einfach mal hier hinter
wisse ja mal hier rein und um mein gott
ohne sitze was hab ich noch nie gesehen
in minecraft dass so ein end portal
genau da ist wo also ich meine im wasser
hallo und hier ist irgendwie noch so
oxidieren drin
ich weiß nicht ob das immer so ist aber
habe ich jedenfalls nie so gesehen
naja jedenfalls ist hier halt ein end
portal und das ist direkt am spot direkt
an der oberfläche direkt an im dorf also
ich kann nur sein wer sich das einfach
nur mega außerdem danke an eine solo
kraft smi den gesendet hat bei so was
habe ich noch nie gesehen das hätte mich
aufgeschrieben von wegen ja was hast du
noch nie gesehenem einfach nicht denkt
so was habe ich noch nie gesehen
hinzu kommt in minecraft mann bricht
ständig den mann und dann das hab ich
nicht gesehen es ist einfach nur krass
also hier sollen sonst stronghold man
das glaube ich da ist das dorf und da
ganz hinten war der spot also ist
ungefähr was meine warum dieser sie zu
geiles und habe ich sagen mit diesem
coolen blicke in die lava verabschiede
ich mich wir sehen es beim nächsten mal
in der nächsten zeit vorstellen ich
würde mich über einen daumen hoch freuen
wenn es euch gefallen hat das zeigt mir
so eine rezension ob dies gut vorne
blabla vielleicht schafft wieder für
plattform hoch für diesen richtig geilen
sieht auf jeden fall
und ich würde sagen ist einfach eine
ecke verschwindet hier noch ein bisschen
und hier ist wasser darunter das heißt
wir am netz obsidian geschaffen
und naja es bis zum nächsten mal